[Music]
Circle ellipse parabola we saw some
interesting things about these conic
sections earlier but remember there's
one more conic section called the
hyperbola it looks like two parabolas
which are mirror images of each other
but that's not the case a hyperbola is
very different from a parabola
similar to the other conic sections it
has many interesting properties for
example the cooling towers of the power
plants or the nuclear plants are
hyperboloid in shape but why a cooling
tower should be shaped such that first
it's efficient in the heat removal
process and second its structure should
be able to withstand heavy wind pressure
also third constructing it should be
cost-effective that is building it
should require as less material as
possible hyperboloid is the shape which
fulfils all these criteria it increases
the cooling efficiency has greater
structural strength and requires minimum
usage of material for construction
another area where the hyperbolic shape
occurs is the trajectory of comments
some comets in our solar system follow
an elliptical orbit around the Sun and
they are permanently a part of our solar
system but a comet traveling at a very
high velocity such that it can escape
the Sun's gravitational pull follows a
hyperbolic trajectory around the Sun
such comets passed through our solar
system only once
isn't the hyperbola an interesting shape
let's understand what exactly a
hyperbola is consider two points on this
plane let's denote these points as f1
and f2 now consider points on the plane
such that the difference of the
distances from these two points is
constant what do we mean by this
consider this point B let's see the
difference of its distance from these
two points is alpha that is
p f1 minus p f2 is equal to alpha one
thing to note here is that by difference
we mean the absolute value of the
difference that is distance to the
further point minus the distance to the
closer point that's why the point P we
subtract its distance to the closer
point f2 from its distance to the
further point f1 now the question is are
there any other points the difference of
whose distances from f1 and f2 is alpha
yes there are many such points the
collection of all such points is called
a hyperbola consider this point Q on the
hyperbola the difference of its
distances from the two fixed points will
be equal to alpha since for the point Q
f2 is the father point the difference Q
F 2 minus Q F 1 will be equal to alpha
similarly for this point R on the
hyperbola its distance R F 1 minus R f2
will be equal to alpha so a hyperbola is
the set of all points in a plane the
difference of whose distance from two
fixed points in the plane is constant by
difference we mean the distance to the
further point minus the distance to the
closer point these two fixed points
together are called the foci of the
hyperbola notice that unlike any other
conic section a hyperbola is made up of
two curves which are mirror images of
each other
now here we took the constant difference
to be alpha if we take any other number
as the constant difference we will get
different hyperbolas let's say we take
the constant difference to be beta which
is greater than alpha then we will get
this hyperbola which is narrower than
the previous one
if we take the constant difference to be
gamma which is less than alpha then we
will get this hyperbola which is wider
than the previous one so we see that
depending on the value of the constant
the hyperbola becomes narrower or wider
now tell me doesn't
definition of the hyperbola remind you
of any other conic section that's right
it's definition is similar to that of
ellipse we know that an ellipse is a set
of points the sum of whose distances
from two fixed points is constant in the
case of the ellipse we consider the sum
of distances while in the case of the
hyperbola we consider the difference of
the distances so we see that their
definitions are similar remember that
for an ellipse we saw what its centre
its major axis minor axis and so on
really mean also we saw the relation
between the length of the major axis the
minor axis and the distance between the
center and one of its foci such axes and
the relations also exist for a hyperbola
we will look at it in detail in the next
lesson to stay updated and to keep
learning such interesting things do
subscribe to our Channel
[Music]
you